In a previous project, we took a carbon dioxide
fire extinguisher and shot out a round of
home made dry-ice. In this project, we're
mixing our dry-ice with a few other ingredients,
to make a delicious batch of carbonated ice
cream.
You might remember this CO2 fire extinguisher
from a previous video. I started this project
by fully discharging it into this pillow case,
just to see just how much dry-ice we could
collect. From a 15lb extinguisher we got over
5 lbs of dry-ice. Now there's a good chance
you don't have a CO2 fire extinguisher on
hand, and that's ok. This works just as well
with the blocks of dry-ice you get at the
grocery store. Alright, to make some ice cream
we''ll just need to round up some common ingredients
like these. For this recipe I chose to use
powdered sugar, some half and half, and vanilla
extract. Let's start by pouring 2 cups of
half & half into a large mixing bowl, followed
by 1 teaspoon of vanilla, and half a cup of
powered sugar. At this point we can stir it
all together, until the ingredients are mixed
thoroughly. Ok, it's time to put the "ice"
into our ice cream. I'm starting with 1/4
cup of dry-ice, and we'll need to mix that
around gently to cool down the liquid. The
great thing about dry-ice, is that when it
sublimates, it doesn't water down the mix
at all. It just vaporizes right out. When
you notice that the fog stops flowing, over
the edges of your bowl, it's time to add some
more dry-ice, and you're gonna wanna
crush this up as finely as you can. If you
find any large chunks while stirring, take
a second to pull them out and crush them up
as well. It could be extremely dangerous if
you accidentally swallowed one. This ice is
-78ºC, and could leave you with internal
frostbite, and fill you up with carbon dioxide
gas. I was a little curious to know what that
might feel like, so I popped one in my mouth.
Now, if I continuously move the ice around
with my tongue, it doesn't sit still long
enough to bite me. Chewing it up into smaller
bits is a little more risky because it releases
a lot more CO2, making it much harder to breathe.
And the little chunks that stuck in your mouth
actually sting fairly sharply. But overall,
I'd say it's survivable. Ok, when your cream
is cold enough that it has the consistency
of soft-serve ice cream, you're just about
done. Just inspect it one more time for hidden
clumps of dry-ice, and keep stirring until
the vapor stops completely. At this point,
you can go ahead, and dish out your tingly
treat. You should find that your ice cream
looks the way you'd expect it should, but
this treat has a twist. It's fizzy. My wife
gave this one to our little boy for testing,
and once he acclimated to the carbonation,
he couldn't get enough. Well now you know,
how to make a delicious tasting, carbonated,
ice cream using simple ingredients, and a
little dry-ice. If you like this project,
perhaps you'll like some of my others. Check
them out at www.thekingofrandom.com